Hallo Wolfgang. Hallo Stefan, wir stehen wieder in der Garderobe,
denn es ist live Sanon, 200 Leute
sitzen im Saal und wir wollen dieses Mal nicht, nicht über KI sprechen.
Wir werden nicht über Sam Altman, irgendwelche Chatbots, Fake News, all das sprechen, oder?
Aber wir können noch mal kurz hinweisen, Mustafa Zuleiman, nachdem wir ihn besprochen
haben, haben die bei Microsoft unseren Podcast gehört und haben gedacht, der Typ ist klug.
Das wird der neue Microsoft AI CEO.
Ja, also wir sind am Puls der Zeit. Wer das noch nachhören will,
das gibt es im aktuellen Salon. Aber jetzt geht es zum Live-Salon.
Wir haben uns gedacht, dann stellen wir doch jetzt mal den Menschen in den Mittelpunkt.
Der Mensch mit all seinen Begehrlichkeiten. Deshalb wird es ums Dating gehen.
Du hast dich intensiv mit dieser VOX-Sendung First Dates beschäftigt.
First Dates, wahrscheinlich eine der ausuferndsten Recherchen zu diesem Podcast.
Wochenlang habe ich VOX geguckt. Und ja, man hört dann gleich im Salon die Quintessenz von allem.
Ja, und ich habe mich auch gefragt, wie verhalten sich eigentlich Menschen in
Dating-Situationen? Zum Beispiel deswegen habe ich ein paar Clips mitgebracht zum Bachelor.
Dann habe ich mich aber auch gefragt, was ist das eigentlich für eine Haltung,
die wir Zuschauer einnehmen, wenn wir dort Leute sehen, die doch eigentlich
nicht spielen, sondern authentisch sind oder dann doch vielleicht spielen.
Das heißt, unsere ganzen Debatten über was ist Wirklichkeit,
was ist Fiktion, was ist Fake News und was ist das Echte, das können wir eigentlich
auch sehr gut mal an dem festmachen, was wir an Unterhaltung konsumieren.
Deswegen werden wir ein bisschen über Reality-Fernsehen sprechen.
Ich habe dann ein interessantes TikTok-Phänomen entdeckt, nämlich von einer
Anbahnung zu einer Beziehung.
Da ist eine junge Frau und ein junger Mann, die leben in einer WG.
Es sind aber Schauspieler, die spielen das. Aber trotzdem scheint es irgendwie
doch echt zu sein, zumindest was die Interaktion der Zuschauer anbelangt.
Und da kommen wir in ein Feld, wo wir am Ende vielleicht diese klassische Unterscheidung,
die wir immer so machen, dass es gespielt, und das ist aber echt,
überhaupt hinfällig wird.
Weißt du noch, wie wir bei Taylor Lawrence die Geschichte von Lonely Girl...
15 oder wie auch immer. Wir sind jetzt schon wieder im Lonely-Girl-Zeitalter wahrscheinlich.
Nur eben andere Methoden. Ja, und eine ganz neue Art des Erzählens,
denn eigentlich passiert dort
auf TikTok die Seifenoper, die wir aus dem täglichen Fernsehen kennen.
Das machen die dort bei TikTok nur in ganz kurzer Form.
Also auch darüber wird zu reden sein.
Ja, war ja deine Lektüre-These auch beim letzten Mal. TikTok ist das neue Fernsehen.
Was ist das neue Buch, das wir lesen?
Wir lesen von Martin Heggelund dieses eine Leben, Glaube jenseits der Religion,
Freiheit jenseits des Kapitalismus.
Und dieser Autor hat die These, naja, so ganz ohne zu glauben kommen wir eigentlich
auch nicht durch die Welt. Aber wir haben auch nur dieses eine Leben.
Wir können uns jetzt nicht auf die Religion einfach so berufen,
aber wir müssen vielleicht doch den Glauben nicht aufgeben.
Ich habe es auch noch nicht gelesen, aber es klingt sehr spannend.
Es wird weltweit viel rezipiert und ist gerade erschienen.
Dazu noch eine These, äh, nicht eine These, eine Pointe, die ich heute Morgen gehört habe.
Viele Sachen, die wir bisher an die Kirche oder die Religion angebunden haben,
werden jetzt davon entbunden, säkularisiert, zum Beispiel Friedhöfe.
Es gibt also neuerdings Friedhöfe in Form von Gebäuden, kennt man soweit,
Grufte oder wie auch immer.
In dem Falle ging es darum, dass derjenige, der die Standards für die Friedhofs-
und Begräbnissoftware, man hat ja dann nochmal mit Formularen zu tun oder so,
sehr viel Geld damit gemacht hat, das zu digitalisieren,
dieses Geld nahm, um so eine Art moderne Kruft, also ein ganz säkularisierter
Ort, wo man seine Urne lässt, also eine Pilgerstätte für Urnen.
Man kann sich das jetzt grob mit Regalen vorstellen, das ist natürlich ein bisschen
ästhetisch aufgehübscht.
Warum kam das in Deutschland erst zu spät, also lange gar nicht zustande?
Es war der Brandschutz, der denen im Wege stand.
Man konnte die Urnen mit der Asche nicht unterbringen, weil der Brandschutz
dem entgegenstand. Das ist natürlich dann eine Nummer zu profan.
Aber so weit kann man es treiben. Wir gucken mal, wie weit Martin Heckl unterstreibt.
Wir schauen mal, ob wir da eine Alternativreligion bekommen oder ob es tatsächlich
ein Glaubensgerüst ist, dass das ohne Religion auskommt und ob wir das überhaupt
brauchen, ob wir nicht auch ganz ohne das auskommen können. Wir sind sehr gespannt.
Du musst noch kurz sagen, wie man am besten jetzt diesen Live-Salon und auch
alle anderen Sanons hören kann.
Man geht auf neue20er.de und folgt dem goldenen Schein des deutlichsten Buttons, der dort ist.
Dann kommt man zu Steady, unsere Lieblingseinflugschneise, weil da das ganze
Archiv vollständig ist, lückenlos.
Alle Kapitelmarken sind drin, alle Literaturen sind genannt,
aber man kann natürlich auch über Apple hören, wenn man es einfach mag,
weil wir da einfach die Salonfolgen im normalen Apple Feed einspielen.
Oder per Patreon, wenn man schon einen Account hat und Account Armut.
Das ist eigentlich ein kleiner Widerspruch. Man hat schon einen Patreon-Account
und wir fordern einen Account Armut ein, aber falls es bei jemandem so ist,
dann kann man bei Patreon einfach buchen.
Oder man kann einfach, wenn man den Podcast bei Spotify hört,
auch dort auf den Button gehen, wird dann zum zum Steady-Salon gelotst.
Alles ganz einfach und wir freuen uns und gehen jetzt gleich auf die Bühne. So ist es. Bis gleich.
Guten Abend. Hallo. Hallo.
Wir begrüßen euch.